okay so today we're going to talk about
two different readings and i'm going to
try to stitch them together for you
that makes sense
and they're a little bit just right from
each other one is this guy alistair
mcintyre he started talking about last
class
he's a virtue ethicist
still alive
teaches at notre dame teaches
undergraduate classes by
choice
the other guy we're going to read is a
famous 20th century
french philosopher john paul sartre and
we're going to look at his
existentialism as a humanism
and there's some common themes that tie
them together magnetary actually talks a
little bit about sarc in that reading
and i'm not presuming that you
understand at this point how they fit
together but hopefully by the end of
this you know and i want to start out
with this
this is kind of a good distinction to
think about
today we're going to talk a lot about
two different moral theories
one of which we call relativism the
other one we call emotivism now they're
both very prevalent in our culture and
in our educational culture
we want to get away from them
they're sort of the end of ethics if we
buy into them we may as well just end
the class here and say yeah everybody
you know gets whatever grade they get
and we're finished there's no point in
studying anything if relativism is true
or emotivism is true
then
there's not much point in ethics
the reason why we're going to look at
sartre is he he espouses a kind of
emotivism
you can see emotivism and relativism at
work in our culture
by looking at this distinction
when we get into discussions about moral
issues
things that people consider to be right
or wrong good or bad how we should order
our lives or our goods or our societies
or relationships
there's a huge difference between
asserting that something is the case and
then asserting that something is the
case because and then giving some sort
of reason or explanation or
justification
a lot of times this this
slips out of people's minds
so think about all these controversial
issues that you know
we like to talk about
you could find hundreds of them
think about daytime talk shows i'm sure
some of you have indulged every once in
a while and watching
some people get into an argument it's
probably a moral argument you should do
this you shouldn't do this
on those shows and they get very heated
sometimes they throw chairs at each
other the guards have to hold them back
right
that's probably not your experience in
everyday life i hope a lot of you are
getting into brawls
but you've probably gotten some heated
exchanges about moral issues
when you go home at thanksgiving or
christmas or easter or whatever
there's certain issues that in flight
conversation you're supposed to avoid at
the dinner table
you know what though what are they
sex is one of them politics religion
money yeah well
it's interesting because usually people
obviously politics and religion
and then the other two that vary because
we like things in threes right are
either sex or or money
now if you think about these why are
these
such hot button
things
well
money
is
always tied in with all
how you earn your money whether you've
got enough money whether other people
should have that money or not
what you spend it on what you shouldn't
spend it on these are things that people
get worked up about
consumption
and purchasing are not value neutral
things as we said
sex well you know there's
there's all sorts of ways in which you
might be able to screw up your life or
enhance it depending on what you do you
know in the realm of attraction
and dating and sexuality and people have
some pretty strongly held beliefs about
that right and we also have some pretty
strong drives
that often bring us into competition
with each other
or run us into societal norms
make us want to choose this rather than
that
politics what is politics about it's
about who has power who gets to decide
important things
you know who should rule
and then religion you know why do people
get so worked up about religion
well you know if there is a god
sarc for example says there isn't that
we're going to look at this stuff today
and we're not going to go very deep into
any of these sort of theological issues
but if there is a god
and god's what you know people who
believe in god
make him or it or whatever out to be is
this you know source of all value and
goodness well that would really reorient
things wouldn't it
and if there isn't a god well that would
really reorient things as well
people often have very
deep emotional investments in these
these issues
and so what happens when they get into
discussions
if they're being reasonable if they're
being rational
they're acting like
what human beings could do
they would say i think this is the case
and make a claim
and then they'd say because
and then they would give some sort of
justification or some sort of reason
i think that you shouldn't spend your
money on candy because it'll rot your
teeth it's kind of a trivial example
i think you shouldn't spend your money
on candy because i think you should put
it towards a marist education a little
less trivial example those are moral
claims
i'm giving you a reason
that's different than just saying i
don't think you should spend your money
on candy
or i think capital punishment is a-okay
or i think capital punishment is wrong
or people who believe in capital
punishment are
barbarians with a medieval mentality
or people who don't believe in capital
punishment
are weaklings
who
coddle criminals and
victimize the victims once again
if you notice those are all just
assertions that they're not saying
anything
because they're not giving a reason
and what happens when we get into
discussions about these
these issues
it turns into you guys are familiar with
this from experience
this side says this this side says this
and they just shout at each other
pretty common experience right in our
society common experience in in every
society by the way
but successful societies
teach their members how to get to the
because how to reason with each other it
doesn't mean we'll actually convince
each other
but if you can give reasons why you
think something is the case you're going
further than just yelling and shouting
at people
unfortunately our
culture often tells us that the key
thing is just to express ourselves
express your point of view
make your opinion count
your opinion is really only going to
count if
somebody else could find it reasonable
and that's where the because comes in
so
what happens oftentimes
in our society this is where relativism
and emotivism come in
is the focus on this
rather than moving beyond to try to find
some sort of reason some sort of
common ground by which we could work
these things out
and justify this place
relativism
says that
there are no actual objective
moral values or norms
or
even you know things like theories that
would hold for everybody they hold only
for
particular individuals
or for cultures or societies or groups
they're relative to them so when you
hear somebody say something like well
that's true for me but it's not true for
you
that's an example of relativism
if they really mean yeah
why is it an example of relativism and
not just an example of being relative
there's a difference between being
relative you can say that something
appears to be true from my perspective
and that's being relative right
but if you're saying well something is
true for me but not true for you
the word true
the way we actually use that word means
it applies to more than just
one thing one perspective you can say
something appears true from a
perspective
that's not really a big deal
for instance um
let's say we take a
sort of silly moral claim i used this
example in the last class
i would guess that you would think that
drawing puppies is wrong
yeah
now
i'm not actually saying i hold this but
to me it seems that drowning puppies
could be a perfectly justifiable thing
if you have too many puppies you know i
mean it's been done for a long time
in a lot of areas you can put them in a
bag and throw them in the river
and then you don't have any puppy
problem you know and they're out of
their misery
they would otherwise maybe starve or
something like that and you know some
people just like to drop puppies too
maybe i'm one of those people
now
do we want to say that
well you know that's true for me
it's not true for you
for you it's true that drowning puppies
is bad for me
drowning puppies is good they're both
equally true they're both equally valid
that's not the same thing as saying i
have that belief i mean you know and
actually i don't i won't stress this
again
um but let's say i do it's one thing to
say i have this belief
in their contradiction with each other
or it appears this way to me from my
perspective and appears that way to you
from your perspective it's a whole
nother thing to say they're both equally
true they're both equally
valid
one is a good point one is saying think
things are relative to points of view
another is relativism
stating that they're both equally true
is relative yes okay or you can actually
say they're both equally false
maybe there's nothing that's that's
true because nothing is true from any
universal point of view
the trouble is it puts everything on the
same level so it becomes very difficult
to say that
how anybody could in fact be iran so if
you want to be able to say condemn the
nazis
right who everybody picks on the nazis
but they probably you know we still get
some mileage on that because they won't
prove that
if you want to say that what they did
was wrong
saying
committing a holler loss
you can't be a relativist
because if you're a relativist you have
to say well it was it was right for them
wouldn't be right for me
or for our society but it was right for
their society because that was their
their set of norms if you want to be
able to make judgments about whether
things on a higher level are right or
wrong or you know true or false or
things like that you can't afford to be
a relativist
in a much more basic way if somebody
wants to do i always use this example if
you want to be a relativist let me know
because then i can give you the f right
away
and then when you come to me and you say
i don't think that's fair dr sadler i
can say well
of course you don't think it's fair and
it's not fair to you but it's fair to me
that's the way i understand fair
then suddenly you're not a relativist
anymore right because when it comes down
to it most of us are not relativists
this guy
alan bloom wrote this book the closing
of the american mind years and years ago
and he said all college undergraduates
are infected with relativism
i don't think that's actually the case i
think that our society pushes it a lot
and our educational institutions often
push it because
we're afraid of making judgments
because if we make judgments then then
we're being judgmental right
and it's not nice to be judgmental
none of you want to be labeled as
judgmental right well correct but also
providing enough for being a
this
year being judgmental in that case yeah
that's an internal problem with
relativism right
i'm here to actually say it's okay for
you to be judgmental just
have some reasons why you're making the
judgment try you know giving some some
justification for why you're saying this
is right or this is wrong as a matter of
fact i would say you have to be
judgmental if you're not
you're you're you know
you're going to let a lot of things
slide that shouldn't slide you're going
to go along with a lot of things that
you shouldn't go on with
very often people talk in a relativistic
way when they want to manipulate people
and that's you know sort of secretly
there or they want to avoid criticism
oftentimes it can be good to undergo
criticism
so that's relativism emotivism which is
what mcintyre talks a bit more about and
he actually this is one of his major
books after virtue
he begins this i'll put some references
to this and i learned for you i'm not
going to require you to read it but
couldn't hurt you
he talks about emotivism as being sort
of the the general moral theory
governing our our culture today
motivism is a little bit different than
relativism
motivism
will also put a stop to ethics
but it'll do for they'll do so in a
different way for a different reason
the emotivist can say people will give
reasons
and it might not just be
if those reasons might just not be well
it just appears this way or this is my
culture's norms or something like that
but ultimately those reasons are just
sort of window-dressing
what the emotivist is committed to is
saying something like this
what moral judgments moral values ways
in which we order goods our lives
relationships what those boil down to
is just our subjective preferences
so
if i say drowning puppies is bad it's
not because drowning puppies really is
bad and that's part of the way the world
is or anything like that it's just i
feel bad about drowning puppies
you know and i feel good in saying let's
not drown puppies
that makes me feel like a good person
and there are people out there who make
their moral claims
and make their moral decisions basically
on the basis
of wanting to feel good about themselves
or not feel bad about themselves
maybe to feel morally superior to other
people
or to avoid shame or something like that
there are people out there who who take
their sides and take their stances
and it's basically
the equivalent of
as one of them proponents of the
emotivist theory said it's basically
like saying yay
you know not drowning puppies yay
drowning puppies
it's just a preference
if emotivism is correct
then all this justification stuff and
the moral theories that we use
these are just a mask
for our wish to get things to go the way
we want them to to make us feel
good now there's a further use though we
also use this stuff to try to make other
people feel the way that we do to
if you're an emotivist it's a okay to
try to make everyone else feel like you
because you know the ultimate basis
is your feelings
so
if i don't want you to drown puppies or
kittens for that matter or you know
whatever
i should bring pressure to bear on
and try to make you feel bad if you do
that sort of thing
on the other hand if i want you know you
to let me
draw on puppies because i'm a sadist or
something like that then i would you
know come up with some sort of argument
that makes you feel bad
for
interfering with my rights to do as i
wish with my property or something like
that but it's really about my wish to
drown puppies
or kittens or whatever
you can see this is going to be a big
problem right if all that morality is is
just our subjective preferences
um what's the point in studying all this
i guess just to get good at tricking
each other
so you learn a little kant so you can
bring that out to
make people feel a certain way
learn a little plato do the same thing
if that's the case then we may as well
end this semester here
right so relativism and emotivism
i'm not saying there aren't any people
out there who hold these theories
they would prevent you from doing any
real study in ethics they would prevent
you from actual growth
both intellectually and immorally
so mcintyre is going to take off
from this this starting point
and
mcintyre
let's do a little recap from from a
little bit that we talked about last
month mcintyre said that um
he said that plain persons so that's you
that's also me and so far as i live a
life outside of the confines of this
classroom and my my uh
academic life
all of us live out some sort of moral
theory
some people actually are emotivists
right some people
are just using value judgments and moral
language to manipulate people right to
coerce them into doing things
does that mean that everybody is no but
but that's
one possible moral theory that you can
have
and our society often
steers us towards it our culture
whether we like it or not does in fact
steer us towards emotivism
in part by discouraging us from actually
giving good reasons
you know when somebody if you've been
told since you were a kid
your opinion
is good because it's your opinion and
you should act on your feelings
you are probably going to end up at
least that early on becoming an
emotivist right
if you don't have anything else telling
you
no you should make a decision on other
grounds
and
when
mcintyre talks about this he talks about
this in terms of this guy
john paul sark
who we're going to talk a little bit
more about towards the
end of class
one of the readings for today
not everybody's an emotivist though
right
when you guys make
moral decisions and you've made a lot of
moral decisions in your life
what other bases might you have made
them
now you probably didn't think of it in
terms of
utilitarianism
did anyone
when they were deciding you know what
they needed to do in their last crisis
say what would jeremy bentham say
no none of you none of you did that
probably you're not going to do that
later on either
but now you at least know it's
utilitarianism
what utilitarianism is
if we want to put it in a nutshell
the approach that it takes
is to say well you know when we make
moral decisions decision decisions that
really count things about right and
wrong good and bad
the best thing to do
or the right thing to do
is that which will benefit
the majority of the people or the
greatest number and harm the the least
amount
so
you could do like a cost benefit
analysis you're going to do some sort of
action and it will affect your community
or your family you look at how it's
going to affect all the different
members
and you try to pick the thing that will
do the most good and the least harm
now that means that um
you can't just do whatever pleases you
right
because oftentimes
doing what will produce the most benefit
the least harm for most people is that
always the thing that pleases you the
most
think about you know you get into a
conversation with somebody
and
you think that they're a jerk
and you'd like to tell them that
but they're friends with
a lot of people that you care about
and
if you were to indulge yourself in what
you'd like to do
you'd like to really call that person a
lot of names
they'd be kind of emphatically phrased
you know
and you you try to
put them in the box that they deserve to
be in
that's what you feel like doing
right
um but you realize oh if i do that
that would feel good to me
and and yeah of course that would hurt
that other person but they're a jerk and
they got it coming but it would hurt all
these other people too
and so what do you do
you bite your lip and you don't say what
you think
take a deep breath and you know no you
don't you say it
when i was your age i i said it too
actually
but i had to learn from experience a
utilitarian would say well you know
let's see how it works out for the
majority so you can't just indulge
whatever it is you want to do that's a
different moral theory that's a
different way of orienting your life
a person who has a utilitarian
moral theory is going to act differently
than somebody who's just following their
desires aren't they
now the utilitarian
is not committed to saying that anything
is truly right or wrong
one of the
things about this is
you know if it worked if it would work
out
good overall for the majority of the
people you could do some bad things to
other people
like let's say
we could enslave
just five percent of the population
and they'll have no rights whatsoever
and we can make them work like dogs and
we can do anything that we want to them
and that's going to make our the rest of
our lives so much better
if you really had a trade-off like that
the utilitarian would say yeah that
sounds okay
that would be okay to do now another way
you might go is uh along sort of a
macintosh called
conscient or
deontological
i think the word duty
some people would say no you can't do
that
slavery is wrong
it just is wrong
maybe we can come up with some argument
for it but we're not going to go there
right
you don't explain
um that would be a sort of duty case
though you have a duty not to treat
people in a certain way you have a duty
to treat people in certain place
now you might be able to provide some
sort of you know reason for this or you
might just say wow we just have our
duties and i know what they are and i'm
going to do them even if it kills me
or even if it goes against my desires
and inclinations or even if it doesn't
benefit the majority
like here's one example
we've used this sort of thing
over and over again in philosophy
what if you could go back in time and
kill hitler
should you do so
would that be a good thing to do
or a bad thing to do because you'd be
killing a human being right
yeah how does the reason forget by the
way any sort of worries about well if i
went back in time and altered history
then would i exist don't worry about
that right because that gets complicated
but what are you gonna say i'm not
actually gonna answer your question
because it was gonna go oh one of those
times
so let's let's think about this one
person
it's wrong to kill people right
what did this guy hit there today
yeah he didn't just kill one person
he was responsible for the millions now
did he you know individually kill all
these people no but he was he was the
guy at the top and
given the you know the nazi um ideology
if you would have taken out the top guy
things could have fallen apart actually
um so maybe you could have prevented say
the holocaust let's just say just the
holocaust itself and we don't worry
about you know the jehovah's witnesses
or the gypsies or any other people just
just the jews they were killed six
million people
um so one guy one life
as opposed to six million
if you're utilitarian that's a
no-brainer thing
joe hitler
i think most people here wouldn't do it
i would actually myself
i'm not a i'm not a deontologist i'm
actually not a utilitarian either but
um but isn't it your duty to protect
others though if you think about it well
then you would have to weigh duties
against each other right yeah and so
maybe you could come up with a good
conscience or death logical reason for
killing kepler as well but one of the
problems is you can say well you have a
duty to protect life even if it's the
life of a complete you know
mass murderer
i'm bringing this up not to try to solve
this here but just so you can see
some so we've got three main moral
theories in play right now that are kind
of common stances
in our society and you don't see people
coming out and saying well kant says xyz
so therefore i'm going to do this but
you do see a lot of people that are very
duty
right and you do see a lot of people
that are sort of
cost benefit analysis driven and then
you do see a lot of people who
really
they may talk about morality but it's
just sort of a mask for their own
desires preferences feelings that sort
of thing
mcintyre talks about these as
options that you may recognize yourself
already in or recognize other people
he also talks about another one
as being
what we're going to call virtue ethics
he uses
aristotle
as an example here it says
the plain person that's you again
is a proto-aristotelian
meaning you don't realize it yet
but
unless you're fitting into one of these
you're
more likely in line with
at least on the start with virtue ethics
virtue ethics understood
in an aristotelian way that's part of
the reason why we're going to study this
guy aristotle later on in the semester
now mcintyre brings up another thing
that's very important at this point too
so he says moral theories are really key
what else is really cute
narratives
um what's a narrative
yeah it's kind of like the story of your
life well that's one particular kind of
narrative you use the word story
that's
that's a good synonym for narrative
movies are narratives
um
when you do a report like let's say
somebody here was international business
you do a report on say
what took place
from
november of
2011 to today the japanese stock market
you produce a lot of data but you put it
together in some sort of coherent story
you're making a narrative
we have narratives of all sorts of
things cartoons are narratives you know
when bugs money tricks uh yosemite sam
that's a classic narrative
when somebody tells a story on jerry
springer about how
they were cheated on by
whoever
you know that's a narrative
when we reconstruct where all the money
went to in 2008 that's a narrative
all these are stories
and we live through these right because
what is your life like
well it has a beginning it's going to
have an end sooner or later hopefully
much later and sooner
like all of you are very young
they wish you very long productive lives
and a whole bunch of stuff is going to
happen in the middle right
is it all just a bunch of random
incidents
sounded fury signifying nothing you know
use the old shakespearean phrase
no there's there's
connections right
mcintyre is interested in two kinds of
narratives he's interested
in this piece at least he's interested
in narratives of
moral progress
and he's also interested in
narratives of what we can call
moral
decline
and
it's kind of interesting
there are a lot of cultural narratives
out there
that
see the world in these terms
like
at one time human beings
were all very good and then something
came along and screwed us up and we've
just been getting worse and worse and
that's why we're a bunch of heartless
bastards now
that's a narrative of moral decline
isn't it
or you know we started out as just you
know basically one step up from from
apes
and
we've been you know we eventually didn't
develop society and agriculture and laws
and our laws were pretty inhumane for a
long time
and they've been getting more and more
humane and our society has been getting
better and better and better and we're
all becoming you know
really good people
the story of moral progress both these
are probably false too by the way
narratives can be true true or false
depending on whether
things jive with the way things actually
are
you can do this for individual people
too can't you
um
some people their lives
start out pretty good
and then they screw it up and they keep
screwing it up and they screw it up more
and more and more and more
the stories of addiction are like that
quite often
you get to get yourself addicted to math
or crack or something like that
heroin it's it's pretty much over until
you get
out of that
treatment and then they may have more
progress
it doesn't have to be addiction though
it could be all sorts of other things
people make faithful choices one second
people make faithful choices that put
them on a path which then
it becomes harder to get yourself away
from once you have a trajectory set it
takes choice right to make yourself go a
different way
or you know on the other hand people
sometimes come to themselves and say
wow
that's a lot better than where i am i
want to be there
what do i have to do to get there and
that's that's a narrative of a moral
progress
and
for the aristotelian view
we don't start out
all the way at the bottom and we don't
start out all the way at the top
so we're out somewhere in the middle
we have to you know slowly build step by
step by step there's no one single
decision
that solves everything or fixes
everything
it's a bunch of different things along
the way and we're going to come back to
this theme of progress during client
narcissism in
just a few minutes
where are you
you kind of answered i was going to ask
basically like when it comes to moral
progress or decline is it kind of like
the idea that if you keep doing a bad
behavior the more you do it the more it
becomes your norm and you don't realize
that it's bad yes exactly
the what we call the vicious person the
person who's developing bad
habits not only develops habits of doing
things badly they develop a different
mentality a different mindset
i want to make a sort of change of gears
now and go and talk about this guy john
paul talk a little bit about motivism
and choice and then we'll come back
in just a few minutes so the reading
that i had you guys look at is this
existentialism
like i said start an important 20th
century
philosopher
french guy if you want to see how his
philosophy actually plays out
in lives there there is a
narrative that you could read he wrote a
book he wrote a set of books called the
paths to freedom i think it's translated
as the first one was called the age of
reason
and his characters in the in there sort
of exemplify
his philosophy
they're not very
sympathetic characters
so if you're really attracted to start
reading that i turned you off i know it
certainly did for me because i went
through a star trek phase myself when i
was your age
if you also look at his life he was not
a particularly good guy
um
he uh i'll tell you just one tip that
about
he had a another philosopher simonda
boughar
who was also
pretty you know a pretty important
philosopher on her own right beautiful
woman brilliant
sark himself was quite ugly
he actually had eyes going off in
different directions
you kind of look at the tone
and he cheated on him
multiple times
um as a matter of fact he even if i
remember right
tried to get her to cheat on him so he
wouldn't feel bad as bad about him
cheating on her
so it gives you an idea of
you know the viewpoint of this guy has
lived out
now he would have said well you know
philosopher's life and his philosophy
are two different things
but maybe they are connected
now sartre starts out talking about
god not existing
and the reason why he's interested in
that
he thinks if there is a god
then we have a human nature
because you know god would have created
us
and god would have made us all a certain
way
so what would make us you know all a
certain way we're going to talk more
about that over the course of the
semester what would be our essence we
would say maybe it's something like
rationality
or some sort of potentials that we would
all develop together
sarp doesn't think that we have anything
like that he says existence
where you are right now what you come
into the world with precedes essence
so you
have your
feelings preferences your situation that
you're thrown into
your background and it doesn't it's not
the same as everybody
else's it makes you you and then you
decide what you're going to make of it
the great theme in its art is decision
that's where he's a motivist
um i'm going to read you a little bit
from from this this is on page three of
the
one that i put together for you it says
when we say now he's giving you some
gender specific language here when we
say that man chooses himself we do mean
that every one of us must choose himself
but by that we also mean that in
choosing for himself he chooses for all
men for in effect of all the actions a
man may take in order to create himself
as he wills to be
there is not one which is not creative
at the same time of an image of man such
as he believes he ought to be to choose
between this or that is at the same time
to affirm the value of that which is
chosen when you make a choice you you're
unless you're totally crazy you're
choosing what you think is better right
sarda's saying the very act of choosing
makes it better
so
why
the a virtue ethicist or a deontologist
or a utilitarian
ultimately
for somebody like sir because you chose
it
there's no other deeper reason
ultimately just comes down to you choose
it
so you know if you're a complete bastard
who you know drowns puppies for fun
and um
cheats you know old widows out of their
their livelihood throws them out on the
street and then um
you know sneaks up behind
people on crutches and kicks their
crutches up from them
that's what you
choose to be
that's you know
probably a bad way to be i think all of
us would say
that's what you chose so for you
that's good
you're gonna have a hard time making a
case to other people but that's okay
because you're choosing it if you cheat
on your spouse
and then suddenly revise your views
about cheating so that cheating really
isn't a bad thing but
you can choose that
i had so many friends when i was in
graduate school that were
revised their views about sexual
morality when it
became inconvenient for them
because they were married or something
like that
i remember being quite kind of struck by
that
on the other hand if you choose to
devote your life to serving the poor
the only reason why that has any value
is because you chose it
it doesn't have any value in and of
itself sarkman said this is this starts
emotionalism
um
you see what that does to
moral judgments right
sarah thinks that he's liberating people
by saying this but he's really just sort
of pulling the rug out isn't he
if the only reason why
you up to this point i'm guessing most
of you have chosen to be good people
more or less
up to this point is the only reason why
you have chosen to be good people up to
this point is because you've chosen it
and you can't give any other grounds
it doesn't really have much value does
it
or maybe it's just your emotions again
emotionally maybe you just like being a
good person
and if you didn't you'd be a bad person
you'd be perfectly fine with that except
it makes you feel good to
do good things
that's where this goes to
now sark goes a little bit farther than
this
very often philosophers can't be reduced
just to an ism or something like that
and one of the things that stark is
saying here that's kind of interesting
let's say you adopt his point of view so
you're an existentialist you're a
to some degree an emotionalist
when you decide
how it is that you're going to arrange
your moral universe what you're going to
value what you're going to say is good
what you're going to say is bad
you don't really have a choice you have
to do that for other people
they may not accept what you say you
know so for instance when charles manson
says killing people is a great thing we
don't say yeah okay charles manson said
so so i think you know we'll all go
along with that now right we say he's
nuts
but he's actually not just deciding for
himself he's deciding for
humanity in general if you decide to be
totally ruthless you're saying everybody
should be like that
if you decide that we should in fact
serve those who are more vulnerable than
ourselves and take care of them you're
saying everybody should be like that
that's a good thing
that goes along with
the structure of human action
so whether you like it or not the story
that
is your life
is not just a story for you
it's a story of how you're trying to
make sense of how a person wants to be
this goes back to mcintyre's point about
it none of you i think none of you have
actually sat down and said
what is the the basic human good and how
shall i achieve it
does anybody ever do that on the weekend
no
maybe you will this weekend probably
um
but you have thought to yourself
what do i want
what do i need to do in order to get
that what do i have to do to put myself
on that track am i making progress
towards that or am i actually going away
from that
and sometimes you actually
pass through plateaus you say wow i
thought this was really good but there's
something even better
beyond that that i need to
change my my priorities for now
that would be moral progress
sarps
is kind of stuck
virtue ethics would take us further than
that
so this is the last thing i'm going to
talk about
with these points of view once you've
got it you've got it
utilitarianism is pretty straightforward
as a theory
um you know you end up doing something
like a cost benefit analysis you can get
better at doing it you can get worse or
you'd be worse at doing it but once
you've got the basic principles down
that's it right you can recognize the
basic principles okay okay same thing
with with uh
stuff even though it is difficult once
you've got it down that you know you're
done
now it's just a matter of application
with virtue ethics this is one of the
points mcintyre is trying to make to you
in this piece
there's a there's a back and forth
between the moral theory and the
narrative
you never fully understand the moral
theory until you've lived it up
when it comes to virtue ethics
you often don't fully understand your
narrative that you're living until you
can get a vantage point later on like
you know think about
what you thought was important to you in
high school
you guys are now three years into
college
at least one of them is four years um
have your priorities changed
have your evaluations of what was
important and what you want to be
thinking about and spending your time on
is that
probably radically changed right
your narrative has changed
you've gotten a better
grasp of it
when you went back home for like the
maybe not the first time you went back
home but a couple times after that you
got you looked at some of the people who
didn't go to college
in high school he said i don't have as
much in common with these people anymore
they were still in the same narrative
right
the way it works is in the narrative of
your life
if you're making moral progress things
get clearer and clearer and clearer to
you as you go on
on the other hand
if you make the wrong choices
there are some choices that you can make
that place you in a path where you can
see less and less clearly where you
develop something like what mcintyre
calls moral blindness
so the example that i'm going to leave
you with
think about wealth
why do we want money if we're normal
there's there's reasons you know there's
some crazy reasons like some people like
to roll around and dollar bills
that's a weird thing right why do normal
people want money
you need it
why
yeah
okay that's a great to provide for your
family
it's it's a means
and in this part of it at least your
family is the ends right
and which is the higher value the money
or your your family and the life that
you can have
the family is the higher value
and so if you have your priorities right
you know think about
a sort of
common problem that comes up in the
course of people's lives do you take the
job that's going to require
you to spend very little time with your
family but is going to generate a lot
more wealth
or do you make the sacrifice
and do without some things but spend the
time with your family
that's a faithful decision that places
you there's one path here and there's
another path here
right
and
if you decide that wealth is the most
important thing which is what you know
stark would say if you make that
decision you are in fact deciding
between wealth and family
and you're not just saying wealth and
family for me you're saying wealth and
family for everybody
that's espousing a moral theory
if you make the decision
that something that's just a purely
instrumental good wealth is the good
and you center your life around that
you will develop a kind of moral
blindness to other values
and so after a while it would be
difficult for you to see what it's doing
to your family
and you've all seen narratives in which
this takes place right
maybe you've lived out part of those
narratives
or your friends have or your relatives
have you've all seen all sorts of
hollywood
uh
cultural productions of things right
because that's a real life
moral decision
that has to be made
and notice when people are making this
they don't always frame it in terms of
normal theories and save themselves you
know how should i how should i arrange
this they they're on the spot and they
have to decide do i take this job
which is going to have these
consequences
or do i stick with this job
i think to themselves in terms of
concrete goods they don't say
oftentimes my family they say
my kid so and so my kid so and so my
husband or wife you know they think in
terms of real concrete actual
goods and values
um and they think in terms of real
dollars do i take the 100 000 job or
stick with the 50 000.
that's the way narratives work
i'm going to give you and i learned an
assignment that has you do some
reflection on your own
life and whether it's been a narrative
largely of moral progress so far or a
narrative of more of a client
so look for that in ilearn
under assignments and i'll see all of
you on tuesday
and then next class will be a bit more
interactive discussion this is good
though good participation well this
assignment do by next tuesday
yes okay uh and and all the assignments
um not only will be posted in ilearn but
you'll you'll um post your
work in high level as well